you can't even pronounce most of the
chemicals in sunscreen he is correct
that skin cancer rates have been rising
but it's not because the chemicals in
sunscreen are causing skin cancer there
is zero evidence for that all the
evidence shows sunscreen reduces skin
cancer it's because we're living longer
so cells have more opportunity to mutate
we have different lifestyle habits
people are going on beach holidays a lot
more and doctors have gotten a lot
better at picking up skin cancer early
also if you can't pronounce something
that's not a sign to be scared of and
I'm sure quinoa and acai are probably
healthy for you it's a sign that maybe
you might want to take some chemistry
classes because then you'll find out
that this is what's naturally in a
pineapple you have two five dimethyl
four hydroxy three true hvonome which
honestly makes oxybenzone a piece of
cake